もう早速やってますねこんにちは初め社長
です
皆さん乗り物
知ってますでしょうか
僕は
知ってますまあいろんな乗り物あると思い
ます車乗ったりだとか
飛行機とか電車とか新幹線僕静岡東京行き
するのでよく新幹線使うんですけれども
政府に極秘で開発されている
リニアモーターカーご存知でしょうか
極秘じゃないですけどまだ実用化はされて
ないんですけれども
実は昔からリニアモーターカーっていうの
を作れてまして検索してます
俺もそれぐらいの知識であんまり知ら
なかったんですけれども噂に聞くと時速
500kmらしいんですよ
だいたい車が普通の道50キロで走るから
10倍
新幹線もだいたい285kgぐらいらしく
てこれをはるかに量がする時速500km
で走る乗り物が今開発されておりまして皆
さん聞いて驚かないでください
今回なんと
リニアモーターカー貸切です
運転できないかはい皆さんあとありがたい
ことにですね今回リニアモーターカー
貸し切って乗らせていただけるということ
で今回こちら見てくださいよ
[音楽]
怪しい施設に来ました
けどこれにはもう大会が開発してる施設で
ございますちょっと入ってみましょうか
はいというわけで早速入っていきましょう
ここ場所がですね
これ
言っちゃっていいのかな場所だって政府の
大丈夫言っちゃって
消されない俺大丈夫かうわ大丈夫なバラす
よこれ
山梨県にいるんですよここ今実は山梨県の
いや結構山の奥の方に来ておりましてうわ
俺これセーフに消されないか心配ですけど
もうわこんな堂々とかじゃダメですよ政府
の方バレちゃうバレちゃう
道端
にもリニア
磁石なんですよね
すげぇ磁力だと思うんで
知ってますで金属と持っていくと
うわーってもう
引っ張られてくらしいから
こちらデンズ探知機です金属の持ち込みと
かここでチェックしたりするんでしょうね
本当に大事なテストの時とかうわーでも
すごい見てくださいjr東海さんいつも新
幹線でお世話になってます本当にここ
なんか
センター試験の模擬試験会場です
絶対違うでしょ
意外とすっきりしてますねこういうやっぱ
人にバレちゃダメな実験してるんで政府の
すげー
早速ちょっとリニア見てみたいと思います
見てくださいこの流線系って言うんですか
めっちゃくちゃ長細いもう先っぽだけ見る
ともうお餅みたいになったこれやっぱ
500キロとなるとでも風の抵抗とか
すごいから多分計算されてこういう
フォルムになってるんだと思いますうわー
[拍手]
形式上で寝てくんねえかな
すごいよだってこことかもうかっこいい
ちょっとまた新幹線とは全然違うね片手が
すげー
うわすげえかっこいいあの見て
コックピットみたいなところすごい近未来
的ですねこれやっぱねちょっとあんまり今
までに見たことない
形だな丸みがあるのがすごいはいという
わけで
リニアモーターカーが実際走っている
場所に行きましたちょっと見ていき
ましょう
すごいねもうしっかり道が作られてるね
これ見てくださいやっぱ新幹線と違って
なんか不思議な白いものがついてますね
あれがコイルです
[音楽]
俺もわからんそろそろ来
るっぽいですねそれこっちが東京側で
こっちがあいつ側名古屋側になってます
はいしっかり時速500キロで来るらしい
のであ来た来た
うわ
早い
てましたよ今あれ
すごいねあれ貸切ってことでしょ今日
電圧です
[音楽]
ここからは結構危険なのでしっかり
ヘルメットだったり
入りますでしょ
[音楽]
[拍手]
すごいね
[音楽]
体感してみましょう
こえー音がすごい地響きだもんもう
[音楽]
一瞬一瞬すぎても
全然わかんなかったな
すっごい勢いマジカで見ると全然違います
ねはいというわけでリニアウォーターカー
早いことがわかりました
思ったんですけどもよくさ新幹線とか乗っ
てるさあ風景とか見えるじゃないですかで
新幹線よりリニアモーターかはるかに早い
んで今から剣聖はですね外でプラカードを
渡しておきますでここに形式は
ひらがな1文字書いてください何でもいい
ですか何でもではないひらがなです
ひらがなだったら何でもひらがな1文字何
でもいいのでひらがな書いて
僕はリニアモーターが乗ってるんで何の
文字かもう目で当てますスロットの目押し
みたいな感じですなるほど
はいこれ
[音楽]
強力だからそうですね見えるように見える
ように
俺も頑張ってリニアモードだからその
500キロになっててこちらの一緒に目の
合わせてからね
[音楽]
見えるのかやってみたいと思います
えすごいすごい見てください皆さんもう
やばいきこの電車ははじめしゃちょー様の
貸切です
すげー嬉しい
嬉しいちょっと家族に送ろう
続きありがとうございます
すごい感動したはいというわけでこちら
リニアのノルバスになってますちょっと
全然新幹線とは違いますけどももう
そろそろ開くみたいです
すごい
車体が見えてますえーすごいっちゃった
けど大丈夫ですこれ
すご
い
スライドした床がこれもいいんですか行っ
てみましょうか
失礼しますうわすげーというわけで
テレビの取材とかは結構あったみたいなん
ですけどもこう一人で行くの初らしいので
行ってみます
これが
未来だ皆さんこれが最先端
超電動リニアの
車内になっておりますなんか形が天井が
すごいな
ちょっと
丸みを帯びてるというか日々の皮みたいな
素材になってますあでもなんかパッと見
結構新幹線ってやっぱ形は似てますねいや
すごいでも新幹線みたい本当に
荷物業もしっかりありますねうわすぎここ
でスピードとかもわかるんだ
続いては戦闘車両行ってみたいと思います
麺がまた雰囲気が違うみたいで失礼します
おーあなんか違うすごい全然
感覚がなんか天井の感じも違うなんか
ちょっと
ラグジュアルな感じがしますねはいという
わけでいよいよ動き出すわけなんです
けれども
貸し切るということで好きなところに座っ
ているらしいですどうしましょうでも
やっぱ一番先頭がここ広いじゃないですか
やっぱこことか
いいんじゃないかな
広いしえここに座りますでここで外の景色
見ながらちょっと時速500キロ体感して
みたいと思います
いよいよ動き出すわけですねはい
次自分アナウンスされました今これシート
ベルトとかないんですか
500キロですよね
[音楽]
ここにもスピードが出ているとですげえ
ワクワクしてきたいやもう十分速いけどな
あ今浮きました
もうこれが
浮いてます
浮いている
北海道新幹線最高速度280度あ
285km
新幹線を抜きました音がすごい
グーっていってるじゃあ320キロ
で320kmですこれは今さ助走をつける
ために戻ってるって感じ320キロで戻っ
てます
今タイヤ
100キロいきました
あ今来ました
本当は音がなくなった200キロさあ皆
さんいよいよ500キロいきます新幹線
よりはるかに早いです今新幹線超えました
ここからさらに200キロ増えるとはい山
とりあえず何も見えないさあもう400
いきそうです
400やばい450
とにかく90やばい500いく
500キロいきましょう
乗っててもわかる
うわー
500キロで動いてます見えますが光の速
さ
すごいなああれ東京大阪間がどれくらい
でしたっけ
東京大阪間約1時間で着けるようになり
ますいや革命だよ今ずっと500km走っ
てるんだちょっと立ってみてもいいですか
500キロの中
は500キロ
移動してます
でもそんなめちゃくちゃ振動があるわけで
やっぱ浮いてるからですかね
あ今原則中磁力で浮いてるからがそんな
めっちゃ揺れるって訳でもないです何なら
新幹線より少ないような気がする
フランスがこうやってたら作ってこと
でしょう
品川鎌倉ぐらい
そうですね
電車だと1時間かかるところを今後の超
電動リニアは8分で移動しております
快適ですね揺れが本当に少ない
快適だ
眠くなりますねなんかあの
僕新幹線よく乗るんですけど
新幹線特有のちょっと優しい揺れで
眠くなるっていうのが
起きてるこれはいというわけで1回500
キロ体験したわけなんですけどすごいです
ねやっぱ磁石で浮いてるから乾かないん
ですけど揺れがそんなになかったです本当
に
言ってること今は車輪で動いてるんで
仕方ないんですただそのスピードに乗った
時すごいですねすっきり姿だったそしてで
今往復で戻ってると思うんでちょっと往復
はまた違う席に使ってみましょうかどこに
しようかなどこにしようかなじゃあ次一番
後ろ行ってみますここにします
2-Dにしますもう今来た
スッて音なくなるんだこれ今何キロですか
360もう早すぎてよくわかんないよさあ
もうすぐ500キロいきます
490500行きました
すげー俺の5001でこれ皆さん500
キロで移動してますよ僕ちょっと歩いて
みようか500キロで
あーすごい全然揺れない
歩きやすい今
合計で加速したんで500キロで歩いて
ました
全リン見てください
僕の移動速でも489キロですいや
めっちゃ早い
移動速度ゼリーの
位置情報アプリだと
追えないぐらいの移動速度ですもん
した
すごいなんか
飛行機が着陸した感じに似てる今減速して
10キロ切りました
すげーありがとうございます
新幹線いつも乗ってる人間ならわかるん
ですけども全然景色の速度とか違いますね
でもなんかやっぱ
浮いてるからかわかんないですけどそんな
揺れとか音とか
新幹線と比べてもなんなら少ないような気
がしました僕はよしというわけで時速
500kmの中でプラカードの
文字が見えるのかちょっと検証してみたい
と思いますいや僕は取りますよ絶対
うわ緊張してきた500系の中でモズ見る
人なかなかいないぞ
でもう終わりました
何にも見えんかった無理無理無理無理何も
見えんかった
じゃあ多分雨とかじゃないと思います
[音楽]
はいというわけで裏カード
肉眼では正直まったく見えませんでした
ただ僕賢いので
スローモーションで撮りましたさすがに
500キロでもスローモーションだったら
俺は見えてると信じたい確認しますもう
ちょいです
[音楽]
いたいたいたいただいて頂いた
無理これ無理だなぁ
偏りすごいですね
すごい今これ
角度で言うと10度ぐらい傾いてるその
リニアが走る曲線のコースらしいです
すごくないですかこれまっすぐ
立とうと
建てませんよこれも超電動リニアの仕組み
の1つとなっております
あやばい
めっちゃ固めてる
新幹線だとありえないぐらいの傾きだと
思いますこれは
すごいこんな傾いてるの乗ってる時気づか
なかったなちょっと今回特別止まって
もらってます止めるのすごいですねでも
[音楽]
お疲れ様でした
ねもう
傾きもすごかったし
速度も本当に
新幹線ずっと乗ってるからわかるかもしれ
ないんですけども全然早かったですもうと
いうわけですごい十分わかったんですけど
も答え合わせ伝えてください
肉眼では見えなかったです早すぎてただ
スローモーションカメラで後から見返した
ところを多分
[音楽]
つだと思います
ではちょっと見るちょっと
確かに俺の
カメラを見たい一応限界で見えたのが1回
ここが限界で
ズームしてようやくほらちょっとさつ
っぽいなって思ってあじゃあ答え心にある
ということで見ますね
答えはこちらです
マジ
あー
でもわかりやすくしてくれたねやけど
スローモーションカメラとかじゃなくて
ほんと無理肉眼だとマジで形式がいたか
どうかも分かんなかったです一瞬
全てが
皆さんあのーもしリニアが発展してもこう
何かプラカードとかで愛の告白はできない
ということをぜひ覚えておいてくださいと
いうわけで超殿堂リニアはもう本当に未来
を感じましただって東京大阪間が新幹線
だったら2時間半かかるところがもし普及
したら1時間で縮まるんですよもうほんと
多分日本の未来が変わる画期的な乗り物だ
と思うのでぜひ皆さん開発をお楽しみに
以上セーフの秘密組織からでした
[音楽]